where you speak very candidly I'm very
vulnerable about your own experiences
that gives a lot of space for other
people to then come out of the
psychedelic closet and I think this and
that and that is sort of that's been one
of the interesting phenomena I mean
there's the book and then there's the
reaction of the book which has actually
taught me and other people in the
community quite a bit about where the
culture is and it's been fascinating to
watch but the number of times I've sat
with a journalist doing the conventional
interview about your new book where
they've turned off the tape recorder and
said can I tell you a story right right
and they have some really big experience
that they haven't talked to anybody
about in like 30 years and it was
something that actually still they're
still processing and my writing am I is
someone who apparently has a reputation
as a affable same person that I was
writing about this gave them license to
talk about it and I've been through this
over and over and over again with
journalists and with people who come to
my events last night I was in Santa Cruz
and this woman came up to me with like
very large eyes and said I know exactly
what you meant I described this ego
dissolving experience I had had and she
said I melted into the creek alongside
Route 17 and these goats came up and
they were sipping me and and now ever
and this is 30 years ago but every time
I see a goat her ego dissolves so I
don't know what to do with this but let
me know yeah but but but I do think that
phenomenon of coming out of the closet
is really important and because that's
how you normalize things we've been
through that with you know gay rights
and
and so many other things that the
willingness to have a matter-of-fact
discussion about something that is
considered stigmatized or taboo is how
you begin to remove that stigma and
taboos and so I've been kind of
gratified that to the extent that I've
been willing to speak in a
matter-of-fact way on national
television or to any audience about this
and that people have responded in kind
makes me think that there is a shift
underway yeah